new york giants had the move of the
off-season with the stunning but not
really all that shocking trade of odo
beckham jr to the cleveland browns and
otto beckham in a lengthy interview with
gq
makes it clear that he wanted out of new
york we already knew that but he also
says he felt disrespected when the trade
went down and and i can understand that
okay he wanted out but he didn't like
the fact he didn't get a phone call
ahead of time and he really didn't have
any say in where he was going to be
traded and look what happened to antonio
brown he basically was able to veto a
possible trade to the bills hand pick a
trade to the raiders get a raise along
the way and it could be that beckham
feels miffed that he wasn't included
more in the process but the bottom line
is he won it out
and he got out
and that's what beckham should be
focusing on and look there's going to be
so much time spent in the coming weeks
and months focusing on what the giants
are without beckham and what beckham is
without the giants and whether or not
beckham should have wanted out whether
or not the giants should have kept him i
think everybody involved would be best
served by just moving on and i don't
know why beckham continues to talk about
the giants
and i i i
i feel like beckham
on one hand doesn't like it when
everybody focuses on him and talks about
him but then on the other hand he
doesn't realize that by doing lengthy
interviews with publications like gq he
gives people more things to talk about
at some point
he'll understand the connection between
the things he says and does and the
reaction that those things generate and
he's always embraced that kind of fame
and notoriety throughout his career and
here we are he's in season number six
now he doesn't quite seem to realize the
connection between the attention that he
attracts that he seems to covet and the
negative aspect of getting that kind of
attention the criticism that goes along
with it you just can't have it both ways
you can't have that hey everybody look
at me personality and then get offended
when people look
and don't like what they see or
hear
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports